Je parie que vous êtes inquiets.
(Rires)
J'étais inquiète. C'est pour cela que j'ai commencé cette pièce.
Les vagins m'inquiétaient. Ce que nous pensons des vagins m'inquiétait,
et que nous n'y pensions pas m'inquiétais encore plus.
Mon propre vagin m'inquiétait.
Il avait besoin d'un contexte, d'une culture, d'une communauté de vagins.
Il y a tant de noirceur et de secret autour des vagins.
Comme le triangle des Bermudes, personne n'en revient jamais pour en parler.
(Rires)
D'abord, il n'est pas si simple de trouver son vagin.
Les femmes passent des jours, des semaines, des mois sans le regarder.
J'ai interviewé une grande femme d'affaires,
qui m'a dit qu'elle n'avait pas le temps.
"Regarder son vagin" m'a-t-elle dit, "est l'équivalent d'une journée entière de travail."
(Rires)
"Il faut s'allonger par terre, sur le dos, en face d'un miroir,
de pied, de préférence. Il faut trouver la position idéale,
avec la lumière idéale, qui sera de toute façon cachée par l'angle dans lequel vous êtes.
Vous soulevez la tête, courbez le dos, c'est épuisant --"
elle était occupée, elle n'avait pas le temps.
Alors, j'ai décidé de parler aux femmes de leurs vagins.
Cela a commencé par des entretiens informels autour du vagin.
et c'est devenu les Monologues du Vagin.
J'ai parlé à plus de 200 femmes. J'ai parlé à des femmes âgées,
à des jeunes femmes, à des femmes mariées, à des lesbiennes, des célibataires.
J'ai parlé à des cadres, des professeures de lycée, des actrices, des professionnelles du sexe,
J'ai parlé à des afro-américaines, des américaines d'origine asiatique,
des indiennes d'Amérique, des femmes blanches, des juives.
OK, au début, les femmes étaient un peu timides, un peu réticentes à parler.
Mais une fois qu'elles étaient lancées, on ne pouvait plus les arrêter.
Les femmes adorent parler de leur vagin, je vous assure.
Surtout parce qu'on ne les avait jamais interrogées avant.
(Rires)
Commençons par le mot vagin -- vagin, vagin.
On dirait au mieux une infection. Peut-être à un instrument médical.
"Infirmière, vite, apportez le vagin"
(Rires)
Vagin, vagin, vagin, peu importe le nombre de fois
que vous prononcez ce mot, ce n'est jamais un mot que vous voulez utiliser.
C'est un mot totalement ridicule, et pas sexy du tout.
Si vous le prononcez durant l'acte sexuel, en essayant d'être politiquement correct,
"Chéri, veux-tu caresser mon vagin?", vous foutez tout par terre
(Rires)
Je suis préoccupée par la façon dont on les appelle et dont on ne les appelle pas.
Dans le Great Neck, à New York, on l'appelle le "minou''
Là-bas, une femme m'a raconté que sa mère lui disait,
"ma chérie, ne porte pas de culotte sous ton pyjama,
il faut t'aérer le minou."
(Rires)
Dans le Westchester, on dit le "petit coin'', dans le New Jersey, "la foufoune".
Ici le "zizi", le "pioupiou", la "languette", là le "kiki", la "poupounette"
j'ai trouvé le "ziguouigoui", la "crapounette", la "bibiche", le "mimi".
(Rires)
On l'appelle aussi le "tutu", le "turlututu", la "bécassine", le "pipi", le "frifri"
"labi", "gladis siegelman", "va", pipi, l'endroit des putes, "nappy dugout",
"mungo", "ghoulie", poudrier, un "mimi à Miami",
un "split knish" -- Philadelphie -- et un "schmende" dans le Bronx.
(Rires)
Les vagins m'inquiètent.
C'est comme ça que les Monologues du vagin commencent.
Mais cela n'a pas réellement commencé là, cela a commencé par une conversation avec une femme.
Nous parlions de ménopause,
et nous nous sommes mises à parler de vagin --
ce que vous feriez si vous étiez en train de parler de ménopause.
Et ce qu'elle m'a dit de son vagin m'a vraiment choquée,
elle m'a dit qu'il était asséché, fini et mort, et j'étais choquée.
Alors j'ai demandé à une amie, comme ça, "que penses-tu de ton vagin?"
Et cette femme m'a dit quelque chose d'encore plus étonnant,
et la femme d'après m'a dit quelque chose d'encore plus incroyable,
et avant que je ne m'en rende compte, toutes les femmes me disaient
que je devais parler à quelqu'un d'autre qui avait une histoire incroyable sur son vagin,
et j'ai été entrainée sur la route des vagins.
(Rires)
Et je n'en n'ai pas encore fini le tour, si on m'avait dit
quand j'étais plus jeune que je grandirais et que j'irais dans un magasin de chaussures,
et que les gens crieraient en me voyant "c'est la Dame du Vagin",
je ne sais pas si cela aurait été l'ambition de ma vie.
(Rires)
Mais je veux parler un peu du bonheur et de la relation
à cette aventure du vagin parce que
cela a été une aventure extraordinaire qui a commencé il y a 8 ans.
Je pense qu'avant que je ne fasse les Monologues du vagin
je ne croyais pas vraiment au bonheur.
Pour être honnête, je pensais que seuls les imbéciles étaient heureux.
Je me souviens, lorsque j'ai commencé à pratiquer le bouddhisme, il y a 14 ans,
et que l'on me disait que le but de cette pratique était d'être heureux.
Je disais "Comment pouvez vous être heureux et vivre dans ce monde de souffrances
dans ce monde de peines?" J'ai confondu le bonheur avec beaucoup d'autres choses,
comme l'engourdissement, ou la décadence, ou l'égoïsme.
Et ce qui s'est passé avec les Monologues du vagin
et cette aventure, c'est que j'ai enfin compris
un peu mieux ce que c'était que le bonheur.
Je voudrais parler de trois qualités.
L'une est de voir ce qui en juste en face de vous et en parler,
et le dire. Je pense que ce que j'ai appris en parlant du vagin,
et en parlant du vagin comme si c'était la chose la plus évidente --
c'était au centre de mon corps, au centre du monde --
et pourtant c'était la seule chose dont personne ne parlait.
La deuxième chose est que parler du vagin
a ouvert la porte qui me permettait de voir
qu'il y avait un moyen d'être utile au monde pour le rendre meilleur.
Et c'est en fait de cela qu'est venu le plus grand bonheur.
Et le troisième principe du bonheur dont je me suis rendue compte récemment.
Il y a 8 ans, commençaient cet élan et cette énergie, cette vague V --
et je ne peux que décrire cela comme une vague parce que pour être honnête
je ne la comprends pas tout à fait, je me sens à son service.
Mais cette vague a commencé, et si je remets la vague en question,
ou essaie de l'arrêter ou de regarder en arrière,
j'ai souvent l'impression de me faire le coup du lapin
ou de me casser le cou. Mais si je pense à la vague,
et si je lui fais confiance, si je bouge avec elle, elle m'emmène au prochain lieu.
Et cela se passe de manière logique, biologique, vraie.
Et j'ai commencé cette pièce, particulièrement avec des histoires et des récits,
et j'ai parlé à une femme et cela m'a amené à une autre femme
et à une autre femme et alors j'ai écrit ces histoires
et je les ai présentées à d'autres personnes.
Et au début, toutes les fois où je montrais le spectacle,
les femmes faisaient la queue après le spectacle
parce qu'elles voulaient me raconter leur histoire.
Et j'ai d'abord pensé, "Super, je vais entendre parler d'orgasmes merveilleux,
et de vies sexuelles formidables et d'amour des femmes pour leurs vagins."
En fait, les femmes ne faisaient pas la queue pour me parler de cela.
Elles faisaient la queue pour me dire comment elles avaient été violées,
et comment elles avaient été cabossées, comment elles avaient été battues,
et comment elles avaient été victimes d'une tournante dans un parking,
et comment elles avaient été victimes d'inceste de leurs oncles.
Et j'ai voulu arrêter les Monologues du vagin
parce que je me sentais trop découragée. J'étais comme un reporter de guerre
qui prend des photos d'évènements terribles mais n'intervient pas.
Et donc en 1997, je me suis dit "Rassemblons les femmes.
Que pourrions nous faire de l'information de ces femmes qui ont été violées?"
Et après réflexion et investigations, il s'est avéré
que j'ai découvert -- et les Nations unies l'avaient dit récemment --
qu'1 femme sur 3 sur cette planète
sera battue ou violée au cours de sa vie.
C'est essentiellement un genre qui est essentiellement la ressource de la planète, et c'est la femme.
Alors en 1997 nous avons mis toutes ces femmes ensemble et nous avons dit,
"Comment utiliser la pièce, cette énergie, afin de mettre fin aux violences faites aux femmes?"
Et nous avons mené un évènement à New York, dans un théâtre,
et toutes ces actrices formidables sont venues -- de Susan Sarandon,
à Glenn Close, en passant par Whoopi Goldberg -- et nous avons fait une représentation
sur une soirée et cela a catalysé cette vague, cette énergie.
Et en cinq ans, cette chose extraordinaire a commencé à se passer.
Une femme a pris cette énergie et a dit "Je veux apporter cette vague,
cette énergie, sur les campus des universités", et elle a pris la pièce
et dit "Utilisons cette pièce et montons des représentations
une fois par an afin de collecter des fonds pour mettre fin aux violences faites aux femmes
dans les communautés locales à travers le monde."
Et en un an, la pièce a été montée dans 50 universités, puis ailleurs.
Et elle s'est répandue ces six dernières années,
elle s'est répandue, répandue, répandue à travers le monde.
J'ai appris deux choses. L'une est que l'épidémie
de violences envers les femmes est choquante, elle est globale,
elle est tellement profonde et elle est tellement dévastatrice,
et elle est tellement ancrée dans toutes les petites poches de tous les petits recoins
de toutes les petites sociétés, que nous ne la reconnaissons même pas
parce qu'elle est devenue ordinaire. Ce voyage m'a amené en Afghanistan,
où j'ai eu l'honneur et le privilège extraordinaires de me rendre dans
des endroits de l'Afghanistan sous les Talibans -- j'étais habillé en burqua --
et j'y suis allée avec un groupe extraordinaire appelé
l'Association révolutionnaire des femmes d'Afghanistan,
et j'ai vu de mes propres yeux comment les femmes ont été dépouillées
de tous les droits dont on pouvait les dépouiller.
Du droit à être éduquée, à celui de travailler, à celui de
pouvoir même être autorisée à manger une glace.
Pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne le saurait pas, il était illégal de manger des glaces sous les Talibans.
Et j'ai vu et rencontré moi même des femmes qui ont reçu des coups de fouet
pour avoir été prises en train de manger une glace à la vanille.
Et on m'a emmené dans l'endroit secret où on pouvait manger des glaces dans une petite ville,
nous sommes allées dans une remise et les femmes étaient assises
et un rideau était tiré autour de nous, et on leur a servi des glaces à la vanille.
Les femmes ont levé leur burqua et ont mangé leur glace,
je crois que ce n'est qu'à ce moment là que j'ai compris ce qu'était le plaisir,
et comment les femmes avaient trouvé un moyen de garder leur plaisir vivant.
Ce voyage m'a emmené à Islamabad, où j'ai
vu et rencontré des femmes aux visages brûlés.
Il m'a emmené à Juarez, au Mexique, où j'étais il y a une semaine,
où je me suis rendue dans les parkings
où des ossements de femmes avaient été découverts et jetés
près de bouteilles de Coca-Cola.
Ce voyage m'a emmené dans les universités
à travers ce pays, où les filles sont violées et droguées.
J'ai vu des violences terribles, terribles, terribles.
Mais, en voyant ces violences, j'ai aussi compris,
qu'être confrontée à ces choses et que voir
ce qui est en face de nous est un antidote à la dépression et au sentiment
qu'on ne vaut rien et qu'on a pas de valeur.
Parce qu'avant les Monologues du vagin,
je dirais que 80% de ma conscience était fermé
à ce qui se passait dans cette réalité.
Et cette fermeture me coupait de ma vitalité et de mon énergie vitale.
Ce qui s'est également passé au cours de ces voyages --
et cela a été extraordinaire -- est que dans chaque endroit
où je me suis rendue dans ce monde, j'ai rencontré une nouvelle espèce.
Et j'adore vraiment entendre parler de ces espèces du fond de la mer.
Et je me suis demandé comment être avec ces
gens extraordinaire sur cette planète
qui soit en dessous, au delà et entre,
et le vagin semble convenir à toutes ces catégories.
(Rires)
Mais une des choses que j'ai vu est que ces espèces --
et c'est une espèce, et c'est un nouveau paradigme,
et on en entend pas parler dans la presse ou dans les médias
parce que je ne pense pas que les bonnes nouvelles sont de l'information,
et je ne pense pas que les gens qui transforment la planète
fassent monter l'audience des shows télévisés.
Mais dans tous les pays dans lesquels je me suis rendue - et ces 6 dernières années
je me suis rendue dans 45 pays environ, y compris dans ces petits villages et villes et communes --
j'ai vu ce que j'en suis venue à appeler les "guerrières du vagin".
Une guerrière du vagin est une femme, ou un homme 'vagin-friendly',
qui a été témoin ou qui a subi des violences incroyables,
et plutôt que de prendre un AK-47 ou une arme de destruction massive,
ou une machette, elles gardent la violence dans leurs corps,
elles ont du chagrin, elles en font l'expérience, et elles s'en vont et dédient
leurs vies à s'assurer que cela n'arrivera à personne d'autre.
J'ai rencontré des femmes partout sur cette planète.
Et je veux raconter quelques histoires parce que je crois que
les histoires sont un vecteur de transmission d'information
qui permet de toucher nos corps. Et je pense que l'une des choses
très intéressantes de cette participation à TED
est que je vis beaucoup dans mon corps et je ne vis plus beaucoup dans ma tête.
Or c'est un endroit très cérébral.
Et cela a été vraiment très intéressant d'être cérébrale.
Ces deux derniers jours, j'ai été très désorientée --
(Rires)
parce que je pense que le monde, le monde-V, est beaucoup dans notre corps.
C'est un monde corporel et l'espèce existe vraiment dans le corps,
et je je pense qu'il est très significatif
de rattacher nos corps à nos têtes -- que cette séparation
a crée une division qui sépare souvent le but de l'intention.
Et la connexion entre le corps et la tête ramène souvent ces choses ensemble.
Je voudrais parler de trois personnes en particulier
que j'ai rencontré, des guerrières qui ont réellement transformé ma compréhension
de ces principes et espèce,
et l'une d'entre elles est une femme qui s'appelle Marsha Lopez.
Marsha Lopez est une femme que j'ai rencontré au Guatemala.
Elle avait 14 ans et elle était mariée
et son mari la battait régulièrement,
et elle ne pouvait pas s'en allait car elle était accroc à cette relation
et elle n'avait pas d'argent. Sa soeur était plus jeune qu'elle
et elle a postulé -- nous avions une concours à New York "Arrêtez le viol" --
et elle a postulé, dans l'espoir qu'elle pourrait devenir finaliste
et qu'elle pourrait amener sa soeur.
Elle est devenu finaliste, elle a amené Marsha à New York.
Et à cette époque nous avons fait ce V-Day extraordinaire
sur Madison Square Garden où nous avons vendu tous les billets du dome rempli de testotérone,
18 000 personne debout disant
"oui" aux vagins, ce qui était une transformation plutôt incroyable.
Et elle est venue, elle a vu cela et elle a décidé
qu'elle repartirait et qu'elle quitterait son mari,
et qu'elle amènerait le V-Day au Guatemala.
Elle avait 21 ans. Je suis allée au Guatemala et elle avait rempli
tout le théâtre national du Guatemala.
Et je l'ai vu monter sur scène dans sa robe rouge courte et ses talons hauts
et elle était là et elle a dit: "Je m'appelle Marsha.
Mon mari m'a battu pendant cinq ans.
Il m'a presque tuée. Je suis partie et vous aussi vous pouvez le faire."
Et les 2 000 personnes sont devenues folles.
Il y a une femme qui s'appelle Esther Chavez
que j'ai rencontré à Juarez, au Mexique. Esther Chavez
était une comptable brillante à Mexico, elle avait 72 ans,
et elle prévoyait de prendre sa retraite.
Elle est allée à Juarez pour s'occuper d'une tante malade et ce faisant,
elle a commencé à découvrir ce qu'il arrivait
aux femmes tuées et disparues de Juarez.
Elle a tout abandonné, a déménagé à Juarez,
elle a commencé à écrire des histoires documentant les femmes disparues.
300 femmes ont disparu
dans une ville frontière parce qu'elles étaient bronzées et pauvres.
Aucune réponse n'a été apportée à ces disparitions,
et pas une personne n'a eu à rendre des comptes.
Elle a commencé à les documenter, elle a ouvert un centre qui s'appelle Casa Amiga,
et en 6 ans, elle a littéralement porté cela
à la conscience du monde.
Nous étions là-bas il y a une semaine et 7 000 personnes étaient dans la rue
et c'était vraiment un miracle, et alors que nous marchions dans les rues,
les habitants de Juarez, qui d'habitude ne descendent pas dans la rue,
parce que les rues sont dangereuses, se sont tenus là et se sont joint
pour voir que d'autres gens du monde entier étaient venus
pour cette communauté là.
Il y a une autre femme qui s'appelle Agnès. Pour moi Agnès illustre
illustre ce qu'est une guerrière du vagin.
Je l'ai rencontré au Kenya il y a 3 ans. Agnès a été mutilée enfant,
elle a été excisée contre sa volonté
lorsqu'elle avait 10 ans et elle a décidé
qu'elle ne voulait pas que cette pratique continue dans sa communauté.
Alors, lorsqu'elle fut plus âgée, elle a crée cette chose incroyable,
c'est une sculpture anatomique du corps de femme, c'est à moitié un corps de femme,
et elle a parcouru à pied la vallée du Rift avec
un morceau de vagin et un morceau de remplacement de vagin qu'elle utilisait pour apprendre
aux filles et à leurs parents et aux garçons et aux filles à quoi ressemblait un vagin sain,
et à quoi ressemblait un vagin mutilé. Durant son voyage
elle a marché pendant 8 ans, litéralement, à travers la vallée du Rift,
traversant la poussière, dormant par terre -- parce que les Massais sont des nomades,
et elle devait les trouver, et ils bougeaient,
et elle les trouvait à nouveau -- elle a sauvé 1 500 filles de l'excision.
Et durant ce travail, elle a crée un rituel alternatif
pour les filles arrivant en âge, sans etre excisées.
Quand nous l'avons rencontré il y a trois ans,
nous avons demandé "Qu'est-ce que V-Day pourrait faire pour vous?"
Elle nous a dit, "Eh bien, si vous me donnez une jeep, je pourrais me déplacer beaucoup plus vite."
(Rires)
Alors nous lui avons acheté une jeep. Et l'année où elle a eu la jeep,
elle a sauvé 4 500 filles de l'excision. Alors nous lui avons demandé:
"Agnès, que pourrions-nous faire d'autre pour vous?" et elle a répondu:
"Eh bien, Eve, vous savez, si vous me donniez de l'argent,
je pourrais ouvrir une maison et les filles pourraient se réfugier et pourraient être sauvées."
Et je veux raconter cette petite histoire de mes propres débuts
parce qu'elle est très liée au bonheur et, et à Agnès.
Lorsque j'étais une petite fille -- et j'ai grandi
dans une communauté riche, blanche, bourgeoise--
et cela avait toutes les apparats,
et les apparences d'une vie parfaitement agréable, merveilleuse, superbe.
Et tout le monde était censé être heureux dans cette communauté
En réalité ma vie était un enfer. Je vivais avec un père alcoolique
qui me battait et m'agressait sexuellement, et tout ça se passait là bas.
Et enfant, j'imaginais que quelqu'un viendrait me sauver.
Et j'ai imaginé ce petit personnage qui s'appelait M. Alligator,
et je l'appelais quand les choses tournaient mal,
et je lui disais qu'il était temps de venir me chercher.
et je préparais un petit sac et j'attendais que M. Alligator vienne.
Bien sûr, M. Alligator n'est jamais venu,
mais l'idée de M. Alligator m'a empêché de devenir folle
et m'a permis de continuer parce que je croyais
qu'un jour, quelqu'un viendrait me sauver.
Environ 40 ans plus tard, nous allons au Kenya,
et nous marchons, nous arrivons à l'ouverture de cette maison
et pendant plusieurs jours Agnès n'avait pas voulu que je vienne dans cette maison --
parce qu'elles étaient en train de préparer tout un rituel.
Et je veux vous raconter une superbe histoire, quand Agnès a d'abord commencé
à se battre pour faire cesser les mutilations génitales féminines dans sa communauté,
elle était devenue une paria, et elle était exilée et calomniée,
et toute la communauté s'était tournée contre elle.
Mais, en guerrière du vagin, elle a continué.
Et elle a continué à s'engager pour transformer les consciences.
Et dans la communauté Masai, les chèvres et les vaches sont les possessions les plus précieuses.
Ce sont les Mercedes-Benz de la Vallée du Rift.
Elle a dit que 2 jours avant l'ouverture de la maison, 2 personnes différentes
étaient venues lui donner chacune une chèvre et elle m'a dit:
"J'ai su alors que les mutilations génitales féminines seraient éradiquées un jour en Afrique."
Enfin, on est arrivé, et lorsque nous sommes arrivées,
il y a avait des centaines de filles habillées en rouge, de robes faites maison --
qui est la couleur des Masai et la couleur du V-Day --
et elles nous ont saluées, elles avaient composé ces chansons
qu'elles chantaient, sur la fin des souffrances,
et la fin des mutilations, et elles nous ont accompagnées sur le chemin.
C'était une journée magnifique, sous un soleil d'Afrique,
et la poussière volait et les filles dansaient,
et il y a avait cette maison sur laquelle était écrit "V-Day foyer pour filles."
Et à ce moment, j'ai réalisé qu'il avait fallu 47 ans,
mais que M. Alligator était finalement venu.
Et il était venu de toute évidence sous une forme que j'ai mis du temps à comprendre,
qui est que lorsque nous donnons
au monde ce que nous voulons le plus, nous soignons la part blessée à l'intérieur de chacun de nous.
Et ces 8 dernière années, j'ai senti
que ce voyage, ce miraculeux voyage du vagin,
m'a appris cette chose très simple: que le bonheur existe dans l'action,
il existe quand on dit la vérité et quand on dit quelle est notre vérité,
et il existe en donnant ce que l'on veut le plus.
Je sens que cette connaissance et ce voyage
a été un privilège extraordinaire,
et je me sens bénie d'être ici aujourd'hui pour vous le communiquer.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)